hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the escalating challenges
of antimicrobial resistance and the
efforts to conquer these threats
presented by dr. Glenn told s'en a
consultant medical microbiologist i'm
susie valdez elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab Lutz
lab Reach is the leading scientific
social networking site and producer of
educational events and webinars before
we begin I'd like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located at
the lower left of your presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on that screen
well answer as many questions as we can
at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
this presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know they're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left hand corner
and follow the process for obtaining
your credits without further ado I'd
like to now welcome dr. Glenn Tolson I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir
hello I'm Glenn Tillotson I'd like to
present my perspective on antibiotic
resistance and the escalating challenges
that we're seeing from a clinical
perspective with regard to emerging
resistance and what are we responding to
these challenges so what I'd like to do
is set the scene give you a little bit
of background some of the complexities
that were facing with regard to ins of
the resistance and then run through some
of the usual approaches that have been
adopted at the moment whether they were
successful or not let's wait and see but
I've chosen seven different programs
projects that I think will give you a
feel for the breadth of activities and
there are second Genuity that's
currently being employed to try to
defeat the the ever evolving bacteria so
let's move along
I just want to declare my disclosures
I'm actually a paid consultant for the
companies listed on the screen and none
of them are actually paid for my time to
to present to you today
nor have I received any other form of
funding for those of you recognize him
this is Tsar Alexander Fleming who is
mentis discovery in 1928 it took about
14 years for the penicillin to be
manufactured but nevertheless this is
Alexander Fleming and since 1928
we have as I put it here managed to
destroy pretty much this man's work and
I think we're all used to seeing these
sorts of headlines whether it's on
printed media TV and so forth when the
drugs don't work the rise of antibiotic
resistance this actually was a front
cover from The Economist last year but
nevertheless the the rise of resistance
has continued and I think the story of
the problems due to these multi
drug-resistant pathogens gets worse
almost by the day
and I think it's important to one to
realize that the the problem is getting
worse and we don't seem to be learning a
great deal of how to to manage it and
the unfortunate part is that really
since the the mid-1980s
we haven't actually discovered any new
classes of antibiotic so we've been
working along the same more classes by
that I mean beats lactams such as
penicillin a my leg like a glycoside
such as gentamicin those drugs have been
around for 50 years erythromycin another
very commonly used drug as a macrolide
first came into use in about 1953 so
we're really you know we saw the heyday
in the 1950s and 60s but since the mid
1980s we haven't seen any new distinct
classes of antibiotic what I'm going to
do through the presentation is actually
describe to you some of the new
potential classes that I think will help
us see some bars to this histogram going
forward into the 2020s so the bacteria
have taken advantage of our lack of
discovery and they are as you
undoubtedly know extremely adept at
finding new ways of defeating our
efforts to control them so in terms of
talking about control the World Health
Organization earlier on in 2017 actually
issued what they called the priority
pathogens list and they broke them into
critical high and medium sort of
priorities so and I've only shown you
the critical and high here because I
think that's where the bulk of the
effort is really being focused at the
present and in fact I think it's fair to
say that in fact those in the critical
watts the a Sunita bomani which is
carbapenem resistant Pseudomonas
aeruginosa also carbapenem resistant and
then the introductory AC which is a
broad tribe of bacteria and it comprises
of a Shueisha coli Klebsiella pneumoniae
entra Baptists and a range of other
species general and and species and they
are Robin and resistant as well as
resistant to
the more potent Beatle actor antibiotics
know here is third-generation
cephalosporins so those are the critical
targets for our current research efforts
but in the yellow box there are still
some pathogens that have hit the
headlines quite recently and in fact the
bottom line of that particular box
Neisseria gonorrhea was actually the
focus of quite a lot of equilibria a
child the United Nations and and other
learner groups they're their focus
because actually I believe it was in
Spain where a strain of Neisseria
gonorrhea was actually resistant to
every normally used antibiotic so
although it isn't life-threatening this
is a you know a major public health risk
and gonorrhea is is back in the
headlines which is unfortunate so that's
the priority list you'll have seen
similar sorts of lists a couple of years
ago from the CDC broadly they're very
similar just a priority Justin the
listing has changed so that's the WHL
priority list this is an image taken
from the CDC website where they're
actually looking at how do we prevent
antibiotic resistance and I think you
know the top three are sort of good
medical practice you know we want to
prevent the spread of resistance back
and that therefore we do that through
preventing infections lots of good ways
of doing that washing hands and so forth
good ways of preventing infections I
think one of the most important things
is actually knowing what's going on
where it's going on and sometimes how
it's going on
so that's tracking and there are some
quite sophisticated tracking systems now
the u.s. obviously the CDC system Europe
we have a phone it's called ECDC
and there are other systems around the
world but one of the things that I think
is is perhaps missing daresay at the
moment is the actual intercommunication
of these
these these systems and because we we
can all travel globally so much more
easily than we could 10 years ago 20
years ago I think it's important for
both in the United States to actually
understand what's going on in Southeast
Asia Central America and so forth
because we can all hop on a plane and
within a few hours we could have taken
or acquired and multi drug-resistant
pathogen so I think the tracking the
global level is really important and I
think they the w-h-o is focusing how to
for us to communicate better with each
other the other component is gaining a
lot of support and again goes back to
good medical practice is that of
antibiotic stewardship or prescribing
now the essence of antibiotic
stewardship is to provide the best
clinical outcomes without doing harm to
the patient but equally getting the
avoiding resistance development and then
I think has been has been the challenges
how do we avoid resistance development
but stewardship in the United States has
taken a twist in the last 12 months in
that one of the government bodies is now
mandated but every hospital in the
country trust they have a stewardship
program so we're going to be seeing
4,000 points of care or not coming the
same stewardship program very very
similar so at least we'll there won't be
a coordination so to speak so that's
those are the three things that have got
core activities and the fourth one
developing new drugs and new Diagnostics
is part of what I pay focus Diagnostics
is is as been sort of a Holy Grail we've
always wanted a test that you can apply
at the point of care whether it's in a
primary care physicians office or
whether it's at the bedside in the
intensive care unit we've always wanted
to have a test that we can take a clay
body but if you read on a sample rub it
on a card or do something with it and
within minutes know what the pathogen is
maybe what the resistance profile is
we're getting there is it ideal No
should we be there in five years I hope
so
look there are lots of logistical
questions and error say economic
questions so until we have better
Diagnostics which will in turn drive
better stewardship we're clearly looking
for new antibiotics new drugs and that's
where I want to expand upon going
forward so where are we today
well the table that you can see in front
of you is it's reasonably comprehensive
I'm not claiming that every single drug
that is in development as an antibiotic
is on there
no no it clearly isn't the preclinical
column the second column in it is
sparsely populated but you will see in a
few moments that in fact some of the
drug classes don't apply anymore because
we're looking at new ways of outsmart
the bacteria but if you go across phase
1 phase 2 phase 3 you will see that
certain classes have been quite focus of
attention and you'll see here
you know quinolones right away across
the middle there's been a lot of effort
into the fluoroquinolone research such
that in fact a fluoroquinolone was
approved by the fda only eight weeks ago
Elif locks us in and that was the first
all IV drug to be approved in the US for
probably about five years so you know
there is activity is it the the sea
change that we're looking for maybe
maybe not but you will notice that in
the duct third clock that fourth column
the phase three slash approved you'll
see there are beta lactam beta lactamase
inhibitors
that's the meropenem vapor brockton
which actually is currently under FDA
review and we should know within the
next week I guess whether this has been
approved and then you've got other drugs
you know minor glycosides not plasm
icing you tetracyclines and i'm sure all
of you have had a tetracycline at some
stage it's those drugs have been around
for more than 50 years
these are new derivatives these are new
glycin cycling's so it's the
tetracycline core with some
modifications and these drugs have got
much broader spectrum of activity and
obviously they they are effectively ins
tetracycline resistant strains as well
as other resistance as well mention the
quinolones I think the Quinlan's have
been one of the most widely prescribed
antibiotics for the last 20 years and
you know you can see that there is
activity in all different phases through
with that class the macrolides both
focus on 50s ribosomal protein synthesis
and there's been focus here three drugs
solid through myosin napped through my
sink and ambulant is about that
so the from IC was actually not approved
by the agency at the tail end of last
year they want some more safety data and
the other two drugs are in phase 3
clinical development the folate
antagonistic lip print trainer it's
based upon trimethoprim trimethoprim was
a compound that was used quite widely in
the late 50s early 60s and very
effective for urinary infections but
sadly ecoli and its brethren learned to
outsmart that one quite quickly so the
clip print is likely to be effective
against those types of pathogens as well
as Mrs a methicillin-resistant Staph
aureus c difficile here means because
it's a pig was on the CDC's list of pad
bugs and doesn't quite make it in the
top categories for their WH o but c diff
is still a major public health threat
still the number one cause of
gastrointestinal hospital-acquired
infections about half a million cases a
year in the US alone so there's been
quite a bit of activity in this field
over the last few years and with some
new classes being studied here or phase
1 2 & 3 so with a bit of luck we'll be
able to find ways to manage c diff
and then on the bottom line you've got
some completely new approaches that are
in in preclinical which is a Spiro
compound is is a other common potentiate
er that's a an interesting way of
looking at how to improve antibiotic use
the hybrid the TD compound is if one be
rightfully at like a peptide in it a
cyclist boring and then chapatis either
the chapattis in I always get my tongue
tied with that punch bodice in new
compound from GSK which works at similar
size to the quinolones but is different
and it can be interesting to see her
about compound progresses so I've given
you a a couple of moments overview in
terms of what's going on mainstream and
I think it's good now to think about
what are the other compounds and agents
through your rap not surprisingly the
bacteria have figured out multiple ways
of avoiding antibiotic Everts and I'm
not going to go into into this in depth
but some of the things that I've just
mentioned like cell wall synthesis
nucleic acid or DNA gyrase activities
folates which is trauma through these
are things that we all know and then can
understand but I think some of the
things that I'm going to speak about
refer to different parts of protein
synthesis and different parts of cell
membrane ruptures so there are ways in
which these resistance mechanisms are
going to be tweaked and challenged by
some of our new activities now to focus
a little bit on the cell wall synthesis
approach to to bacterial resistance
mainly because penicillin was the first
antibiotic and in fact looks like
ampicillin and amoxicillin are still the
biggest is the biggest usage of the
other antibiotics in many many parts of
the world ampicillin is still the number
one in India and many parts of the world
so just to give you a feel for how did
the bacteria circumvent beta lactams
and you'll have heard of multi
drug-resistant ecoli and so forth well
multi-drug resistance usually means that
you're back
possess multiple ways of of overcoming
beta lactams the minor glycosides
tetracyclines and you can see all of the
major classes actually listed in the
little boxes around here well let's
focus on the beta lactams for a moment
there are three main ways and this is
not exclusive and this is not totally
comprehensive but the three main ways in
which bacteria evade our best efforts
one is its enzymatic destruction or
deactivation of drug and beta lactams is
a good example and my glycosides are
another example whereby the bacteria are
able to either are able to add on
chemical moieties that just deactivate
the the gentamicin for example then
you've got cell wall accesses as you all
well know the bacteria needs nutrients
to go in and out and various other
chemicals well pour in surveilling the
doorways that's what allows these
chemicals to enter to the cell the
bacteria are able to alter the size and
shape of a number of those pourings
those those molecular door spoken to a
better word and I think that is all just
a very efficient way for bacteria to to
restrict the entry of different
chemicals and then the third one here is
what's called a flux and bacteria like
most living things have produced by all
waste shall we say and they have to pump
out it's it's housekeeping they need to
export various waste materials
metabolites that they don't need that
may eventually be toxic so they have of
this evil ops mechanism and I'll talk
about the e flux towards the end of my
presentation but I think e flux is one
whereby that this that process can
actually take out multiple types of
antibiotics with the same mechanism so
this is where multi-drug resistance
becomes a real issue with one relatively
simple protein change so what are we
doing on the beach right down front
because it's the predominant being used
antimicrobial class what it what what
are the efforts that are going on at the
moment well
if bacteria produced beat elect amazes
which is how they deactivate on or or
destroy the beetle act on antibiotics
metal act amazes have been around
problem flu for the best part of 30
years the first one of which was
clavulanic acid it was a combined with
amoxicillin to make a drug that I think
everybody may have heard of called
augmenting an ox amoxicillin clavulanic
acid bacteria have found ways of
overcoming clavulanic acid and in fact
we were aware of that sometime in 10-15
years after augmented and people in
taser baktun was was developed that was
very effective against many of the the
multi drug-resistant hospital
beta-lactamase producing gram negatives
such as Ecola
but again the bacteria work out ways of
overcoming what the BL is that means
lactamase inhibitors so currently in
development i'm aware of for I say aware
of for because you just never quite know
what else is going on but I'm aware of
four different combinations of beetle
actor and beta-lactamase inhibitor and
as I mentioned before meropenem vapor
back town is in this latter stages of
review with the the FDA it's a slightly
unusual warning that it's what's called
a cyclic boronate which gives it a
structure that it's likely to be more
difficult for the bacteria to to
circumvent time will tell fingers
crossed
EB pending Silas tatin has been around
for thirty something years
Merc of now I did well aback to answer
that to protect it against a wide range
of intellect amazes aztreonam have you
back time and saw back to man days are
bicycling eggs are other combinations
that are in development but and this is
the piece that's particularly relevant
is that gram-negative species such as
Pseudomonas Acinetobacter both of which
were in the top three nasty bugs from
the w-h-o they have other ways
additional ways of overcoming
beta-lactam antibiotics so
bacon Institute pour in church he fluxes
talk about those in a moment so one of
the other ways is to actually try to get
your antibiotic into the cell and the
back of an essential mechanism for the
cell so
what's affectionately called the Trojan
horse approach and for those of the
don't remind you or your Greek mythology
suggest to go and have a look at the
Trojan horse story at some stage and
then towards the bottom of the slide
here one organization is actually
looking to different molecular
approaches but looking at how to block
the activity of efflux pumps so the
bacteria can pump out the antibiotic as
it is it enters and then to try to
manage pouring changes such that
antibiotics can penetrate the cell so
there's some creative ways of looking at
electron resistance this is the Trojan
horse approach and hopefully you can
follow this through I was going to try
and use the arrow but I thought for the
moment so the design transport system as
many of you probably realize bacteria
require ferrous and ferric ions for
normal maintenance normal function it's
a critical area and Monaco called
siderophore which is a cutter called in
this case stuck on to the side of it
settlers Maureen actually binds to the
iron railing I love islands and because
the bacteria needs them it sends out
scavenger molecules to find the I ROM
and by design pulls in the antibiotic as
well so you've got this ion complex with
an antibiotic complex and it's actively
physically drew robot drawn incident to
the bacterial cell once in the cell the
to split the antibiotic is released and
he goes about its merry way and attaches
to the penicillin binding protein which
are those funny green things you can see
at the bottom of that the other approach
is that
porins are mentioned or rather these are
the portals of earth
molecules in and out again you can the
Trojan horse will allow access of these
particular molecules were there to any
issues and the same applies to to the
flux mechanism there is so the way that
these the Trojan horse works is that it
actually avoids because of its the the
critical nature of the iron means that
it doesn't get a fluxed the other
component is thought the antibiotic
that's actually released is resistant to
many not all but many of the beads back
to mazes so the Trojan horses are is a
fascinating three armed way of
overcoming some of the problematic multi
drug-resistant pathogens okay so where
are we now
well there's a myriad of different ways
of trying to look at new and develop new
antibiotics I wanted to give you some
examples of most of these and I think
it's it's a mark of our ingenuity and
our approach to this growing challenge
that we're really trying to look forward
but also look back and I'll go through
some of these and give me a feel for how
we I think we're actually making some
progress one of the key things that I
think is is particularly important is
that companies academia and governments
actually sat on vast amounts of
information just think of the amount of
information that gets submitted to the
regulatory authorities and the drug may
or may not be approved but there is this
mass of data that's out there and it may
well be of value for future developers
so the Pew trust which is a charitable
organization based here in the United
States has actually put together a
global data platform whereby they're
pulling together all of these different
information sources and making them
searchable shareable so that people come
into the field that we aren't aware of
research that was completed and ten
years ago sir
twenty years ago I think you know many
of us are not as old as me that would
not be aware of some of the research
that was completed in the 1980s and 90s
on quinolones
or on tetracyclines so this global data
platform is a novel way of trying to
bring all of the information together in
a true sort of big data approach and I
think information sharing is one way in
which we can avoid reinventing the wheel
especially it wasn't a good wheel in the
first place so that's the Pew trust
approach to to this challenge and this
is what they are this is what they're
there when it looks like it's got a
spark and it's pretty user friendly even
I can use it and what it does you can
see there it looks at the chemical
structure provides an array of different
chemistry information such as any HTS
end results that were put through and HT
PhDs was very much involved in the 1980s
and 90s it's not quite so involved
nowadays we have different approaches
but there is a huge amount of
information there biological information
it saves having to go through lots more
m.i.c testing animal models and so forth
an awful lot of molecules have to be
registered for patent reasons so those
are on our public databases and they're
accessed here and obviously as molecules
work developed there's expert
commentaries there are published
articles on their activity the
pharmacokinetics and so forth and it
actually this spark poles is all
together so that people will know who is
actually looking at what and how things
are going to move fold so it's a genuine
effort to be be comprehensive and open
and collaborative future discovery
options there's a variety of ways in
which we could tackle this I couldn't
speak for way too long to crack this
topic but I think there are three
components here that I think are
particularly important does this
essential gene paradox whereby we know
that just a small proportion of the
genome of e.coli which is around 300
genes are critical for
but there are 250 or so that are
required in certain conditions so are we
able to target some of these previously
unrecognized genes and actually create
them as targets for antimicrobial time
therapy and some of these candidates in
kill their bacterial response to stress
we've known about both sort of the
stress response really since the late
eighties nineties with some other
quinolone work type 3 secretion which is
the second one here this is being
investigating gram-negative setting and
it's really quite a clever way in which
bacteria can attack our host cells
attachment and nutrients or other ways
in which we we may be able to identify
certain essential drink genes and
conditional genes in order to come up
with different target sites and then
there's the gene protein interactions
which an awful lot of these interactions
are actually highly complex something
fairly redundant in many cases can we
utilize those interactions in which to
Institute something with lethal action
chemical genomics is is a vast topic of
itself from one of the the first
companies I went to speak about actually
is doing some quite elegant work in that
area and then combinatorial discovery
that is an area where by we can or heart
I should say looking at all drugs with
new additions sort of we create a new
combination but using a compound that
we've known and used for many years but
really just sort of supercharging it for
want of a better term so those are some
of the future discovery options but what
I want to do now is run through some of
the different approaches to the
antibiotic resistance challenge and this
is by no means a comprehensive list of
all of the different companies in this
space but these the ones that I thought
helped go to some
the points I was trying to have been
trying to make about the novel ways in
which we have to tackle the problem and
the very bottom line is one that I think
will be intriguing to to many of you as
well so I'll leave that for the moment
the UK company called discover discover
have two different optical platforms one
one is called sateen which as you can
see is selective antibiotic target
identification and what they're doing
here is they're looking at and adopting
something like the pure approach they're
looking at a an array of different
antibiotic classes some of them failed
some of them current compounds that
could do with a little bit of zip to
make them more potent and they're
looking at a range of different
pathogens but simultaneously so if you
think about the different pathogens the
different compounds that's a huge matrix
of information that needs to be to be
assimilated and they can also look at
the different pharmacokinetic and those
pharmacodynamic components with regard
to certain antibiotics can we reinvent
an old antibiotic by giving it once a
day but a higher concentration or things
like that I'll show you you've got the
drift of where I'm going with this so
one of their platforms is called it
satting where they're trying to pick out
certain antibiotic targets and as you
can work your way around the wheel you
can see that you know we know the
mechanism action we know how the
compound goes into and yet pushed out of
the bacterium we can look at what they
can look at how to fine-tune this efflux
mechanism that I described and we can
look at how resistance develops is it a
slow process or is it a rapid single
step process like you would see with
return percent for example and obviously
with the chemistry capabilities of today
you can do structure activity
relationships and assess what the effect
of certain molecular changes would be on
e flicks or entrance to the come into
the cell and then there is the overall
toxicity that's associated with
different molecular classes we know some
are associated with certain structures
others we only find out when we've Expo
to humans so that's sat in and then we
have and this is how the process works
in terms of a library creation creating
mutants and then the mutants are
assessed against an array of different
chemicals and potential antibiotics and
that's a summer a list some of the
antibiotic like aside organism libraries
around the the wheel at the bottom ecoli
staph aureus my Syria gonorrhea and so
forth so you you can see they're forming
in on the WH o--'s list of priority
pathogens this is the program called
silk that I was just about to start to
describe and this employers big data
classic big data huge amounts of
information it's simulator and they look
at screening processes they look at
mutation rates do mutation rates change
in different conditions you know we know
that the pH in infections is lower than
it is in normal healthy tissue so does
that have an effect upon mutation rate
that's the sort of thing silk can can
address it looks at serial kind of
comparable mutations so you can normally
with in the past subjected organisms to
multiple repeated pathologies to
antibiotic and waited for resistance to
emerge this sort of mechanism could
actually predict these types of things
so which you can see all of this
information is combined to look at
multiple candidates simultaneously
against the types of organisms that was
shown on the what I'm going to call the
Sutton wheel before and I think this
sort of big data and genetic
manipulation is it's not the right sort
of way to pull out more focused
candidates for future research went
would then what I'm going to call the
natural world now you may recall going
back today the wheel of different ways
to bring in new antibiotics well agile
pharmaceuticals have actually gone and
water literally under water they have
using
molecules produced by marine organisms
and those molecules are there to protect
themselves one of the problems are being
in underwater is that you can be covered
in biofilms and the biofilms are
produced by unpleasant bacteria and so
forth and destruction of sponges and sea
squirts and so forth and these molecules
may well have important effect against
things called biofilms which are
intrinsic in urinary tract infections
bone infections heart valve infections
biofilms exist almost anywhere that
there is a paid an infective process so
they actually the agile folks actually
work from the compound head jennifer
Erin and Angela Fair in Surrey Chile
ferry and have been manipulating the
molecule adding different components
bromine and other patterns to different
parts of the molecule and they've done
it to such an extent that they have
patented and published a wide range of
different molecules that are
significantly more antibacterial than
the original molecules that you saw a
few moments ago that were recognized in
the you know the late 1980s early 1990s
and it is this chemical sophistication
that is going to enable a natural
product from under the water to actually
be potential value in things as a save
one given infections and so forth so
there we're going to a natural resource
that we haven't been to previously I
think we're all familiar with this sort
of the cephalosporin studies as a story
of you know the Italian gentleman
sifting through sewage to find the right
fungus that produced a cephalosporin
well we're going to a different source
now we went to the healthy and the
biofilm organisms and it's proposed that
these how different they've got a novel
mode of action it's not been seen by the
bacteria that we we struggle with and
they have it what's called a
two-component regulator
mechanism and
the Algerians disrupt those they clearly
disperse biofilms which is a great step
forward and they appear to actually
restore activity of some antibiotics
against the pathogens that we're worried
about maybe they can mitigate the
acquisition of resistance time will tell
the bacteria very very smart sensor
another very very small company are
actually working on non natural those
synthetic antimicrobial peptides and
these peptides work there are only eight
ten minor acids in length and they can
be then literally built such that they
can be tailored for certain species
specific with certain species which is
very much the narrow spectrum approach
of antibiotic stewardship so this is
this is obviously a good way to go and
what happens is they laid on the small
string of peptides gets in and you can
see here that this the big circle shows
you the the lipid polysaccharide the or
antigen as it's called here linking to
the lipid in the outer membrane here at
gram-negative bacteria and the peptide
the Nano monitor molecular pepper
actually inserts itself into both the or
antigen chain and at the face of the
antigen binding to the lipid a and it
basically just cleaves it and bursts a
large hole in the cell membrane and as
you well know you put a hole in
bacterial cells and they just burst so
if you look at the two black-and-white
pictures you can see on the top there
there's a typical image of a bacterial
cell
nice and fat rounded and then one below
where they've been exposed to the spear
had antibiotics the cells have just
lized
so I think that's an interesting way of
tackling the gram-negative problem and
believe that there's also work going on
to look at how to gram positive bacteria
in a similar sort of way so you see
where the spearhead technology takes is
over the next
few years but this is a an interesting
approach to which bacterial resistance
may be slower than some of the other
program molecules we've seen previously
Cosi Cosi pharmaceuticals have looks at
the ribosome protein synthesis now you
may recall that the macrolides work at
the 50s subunit of the ribosome
tetracyclines work at the 30s ribosome
these clever people are going to a
completely different part of the
ribosome called the p site or the 70s
site and this is a novel ribosomal
target site and because of that novelty
it's clear there's a new mode of action
involved here and it means that
organisms that are resistant to the
macrolides and and other similar classes
of all paths of antibiotic resistance
are overcome by virtue of going to a
completely new site and if you look at
the center of this particular image
you'll see that macrolides neko semi
it's going fennec all they work and the
50s component pleura mutants which is
the formula you may have heard me
mention that previously that also works
in the 50s but at the lower end whereas
here the cursor molecule works in a
completely different part of the the
protein synthetic mechanism over
if the ribosome and I think that is it's
going to be an interesting development
program and we shall wait and see so far
the the in vitro and I stressed the in
vitro activity suggests that it may work
pathogens as broaden is Mycobacterium
tuberculosis through to
multidrug-resistant gram negatives my
Pseudomonas Nova biotics they actually
got two platforms so I guess they're
hedging their deaths and one of them
system system II actually has been used
for for quite some time as a as a well
known agent for a NF rhotic condition
the system is actually an endogenous
immune modulator and we know that
actually if you had a system een to an
antibiotic it improves the activity of
the the relevant antibiotic whether it's
when along mnemonic like aside at all
whatever so the combination of system
een a compound as I say that has been in
clinical practice for probably about
thirty years in a rare disease the rare
condition but nevertheless used
significantly and safely major issue
there over many years and if you could
add that to an antibiotic that is been
established as I say invalid life side
so forth you could actually reinvigorate
and that was one of the other squares in
how to develop new antibiotics
repurposing well reinventing an old drug
and in fact there is a study ongoing
looking at system een with an antibiotic
it's actually minded like side in the
study of cystic fibrosis
now cystic fibrosis is it's not a common
infection or it's a common condition but
infections can be life-threatening and
certainly over the period of a lifetime
of a CF patient the repeated infections
really have a significant problem it's
also been shown that the system in with
antibiotic and disrupt biofilms which
again goes to the cystic fibrosis
component will also contribute to youth
useful clinical activity in complicated
urine infections and possibly things
like ventilator associated pneumonia
where the pneumonia develops really from
a biofilm developing on the inside of
the the ventilator tubing the other
platform that no robotics are looking at
involves engineered peptides and again
it's a little bit like the sensor
program they can actually engineer the
peptide to specifically target the cell
membrane of the back
to found also fungi in this particular
instance and they described a starburst
activity on the membrane and rapid lysis
and they seem to be able to build the
the amp as it's called the peptide for
each pathogen as I mentioned before it's
as though the map the pathogens have got
a unique lock and key
so that's Nova biotics Corinth era pew
ticks were looking at : sensing and to
interfere with quorum sensing because
that's the the way in which the bacteria
recognized there's something going on or
an opportunity to infect and it can
control virulence and this complex
picture shows you what's called an
accessory gene regulator that switches
on and approve the production certain
farallon's mechanisms and toxins and the
folks at attack on sensitive corn
therapeutics have developed a small
molecule that actually blocks a critical
part of this a quorum sensing perfectly
and it blocks what's called a kg or a
component and by blocking this component
this pathway it should be that we we
reduce or completely eradicate the toxic
effects certain bacteria in here they've
been looking at staph aureus so this is
a new way affect the virulence and
actually ameliorate the effects of the
disease and maybe even prevent the
disease microbiotic s-- is a company
that's focused on to coupon two things
one is type 3 secretion and this is
where bacterial proteins are ruptured
translocated or injected and here you're
looking at the syringe sort of upside
down and where all the different circles
are at the bottom that's where the
protein is manufactured and it's
injected up into the target cell the
holds itself and we know that the
Pseudomonas type 3 secretor will kill a
whole range of different immune
protection cells such as macrophages and
neutrophils
and type three sequences are known to be
a source of with poorer disease outcomes
we talked earlier about efflux pumps
this is a very complex efflux pump
called the RND RND can confer a wide
range of different resistances to
different agents handling the bioscience
and one of the things that that this
company is looking at is how to inhibit
the way in which these e flux pumps work
and the potential benefits are
significant committed towards the end
here antibiotic resistance resistance
breakers and I acknowledge David Brown
and Ed's paper is well worth the visit
if you have the chance and he's done
kids or another workers have done have
looked at compounds that we've used for
years berberine CERCLA products more
paranoid one of the classic
anti-diarrheal drugs they all of these
have got some activity either on the
immune system or directly on the bone
and the bacteria themselves circular
arcs works on inhibiting liquor
polysaccharides in gram negatives and by
the way it can block some of the immune
reactions so each of these listed here
have got some potential in terms of
interfering with the resistance process
either direct antibiotic and bacterial
activity they can improve other
antibiotics in terms of resistance or
they can actually clear the infection
eradicate the infection by blocking some
of the host responses that can lead to
the inflammatory process so just to show
you the internal ingenuity of
microbiologists and where they look for
for the next penicillin couple here that
caught my eye
one is is the Australian researchers
that actually found in the Tasmanian
devil milk so clearly you know not an
easy source to get at but milk from
Tasmanian devils will actually kill a -
a as it says here
milking Tasmanian devils is not an easy
process and then there is open another
group that have actually
that there is a novel antibiotic that's
been found in the nests of leaf cutter
ants so our ingenuity is appearing to
have no limits and I hope them whether
it's Tasmanian devil milk leaf cutter
ants or some of the ingenious mechanisms
that I've just been describing actually
provide us with new weapons against
antibiotic resistance thank you for your
attention thank you so much dr. Tolson
for that informative presentation and
thank you so much for your research we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green e Q&A button at the
lower left of your presentation window
type in that question in the box that
appears on the screen and click the send
button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
audience member has a question
dr. Tualatin how long does it take the
identity to identify a drug and get it
approved okay it takes anything from 15
to 20 years for an antibiotic candidate
drug to be identified studied in the
clinical trial programs and then be
approved by the regulatory processes but
it's important to note that not every
drug that goes into that process makes
it all the way through so anything from
15 to 20 years we are getting quicker it
is still takes a long time
thank you so much and here's our next
question we have a lot of wonderful
questions coming in how many candidates
have have to be tested to arrive at a
possible agent typically we would say
that 5000 candidate molecules would lead
to a single viable compound and a lot of
those 4999
are excluded for reasons of or activity
toxicity the pharmacokinetics are not
ideal for for human administration and
so forth so the attrition rate is is
quite high and I think it's higher in
antibiotic development than in other
branches of pharmaceutical research
because other far other branches work
with homo sapiens
here were working with homo sapiens and
a third party the bacteria or fungi so
we've got to let another layer of
complexity onto the process of finding a
candidate and then putting it through
his paces
so one in 5,000 is the typical sort of
hit rate
Thank You dr. Tolin saying this is such
important information here's another
important question from one of our
audience members what does it cost to
develop a new antibiotic I would say
with today's technologies and the more
focused approach that we have that we
had say 20 years ago I would say they
can cost anything from 500 to 750
million to bring an antibiotic to the
clinic now part of that obviously is
fracturing in the ban the costs of those
four thousand nine hundred or so drugs
that didn't make it but nevertheless to
actually take an antibiotic to all its
paces to meet the regulatory
requirements and so forth is a minimum
five hundred million dollars
thank you sir we have time for one last
question from our audience members it
looks like we have several just a
reminder go ahead and send them through
and we will get to you as soon as
possible why does it seem to be only
small companies in this field dr. Fulton
yes that's a very good question without
wishing to be cynical I think a lot of
the large pharma companies have how can
I put it stepped back from some of the
research initiatives that they had 2025
years ago mainly because of the the
challenges of bringing new antibiotics
to the clinic
I think the moment the small companies
have the of the field because they are
compact they are responsive they are not
the huge megalithic organizations that
some of the other old companies are and
I think many of the companies that I've
referred to in my presentation are
literally less than 20 people in fact I
know two companies that are literally
three and four people so they're a lot
more flexible they can adopt a thing to
to ideas and challenges much more
rapidly and I think once a drug is looks
like it's being proven looks like it's
living up to the hype then I think the
big companies step in and take the drug
through its last stages with FDA and PMA
and that's when the that's when the big
box are needed that's when you need the
you know eighty-five million dollars to
do one clinical trial that's when the
big guys come in but a lot of the early
innovation is is driven by the small
companies and in fact a number of those
initiatives actually are coming from
universities and other academic settings
where someone has a bright idea it gets
turned into a small company and it grows
from there so I think innovation and
flexibility of the two hallmarks of a
small company
but the sheer mechanics and investment
comes from from Big Pharma Thank You dr.
Tolson for your presentation before we
leave audience members thank you so much
for being here today doctor told him do
you have any last comments you'd like to
share with your audience today thank you
Susie I think let me started off on a
note of true pessimism that we managed
to destroy Fleming's work within within
70 years I think with the awareness of
how to use antibiotics more
appropriately both clinically
economically and a lot of the innovation
that it's driving at research ahead a
moment I would hope that in the next 70
years we actually see this trend
reversed and not naive enough to think
was suddenly going to see a wave of new
antibiotics but I think people are now
aware of what's what's happening and
this impending tsunami of resistance so
I've had don't want anybody to think
that you know we've got the Armageddon
bacteria around the corner I think we
have the science the skills and the
tenacity to actually turn this thing
around and I look forward to the next 10
20 years so thank you
I would like to once again thank you
again dr. Watson for your presentation
I'd also like to thank lab roots today
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again bye-bye